hey guys I'm back I just finished a
tournament in Spain now I'm in Prague
and I'm gonna have a lot more free time
coming up to do do more YouTube
exclusive videos so I got a message a
week or two ago from someone online I
think he follows my content who asked me
if I could do this test this alone
either test which I've never heard of
it's called Elim ethernet and this is
actually my first time visiting the
sites
I haven't even fully read the
instructions here but essentially it's
some kind of test to measure your
reading simply this doesn't take too
long and I would encourage anyone who's
watching if you haven't done this before
maybe stop the video here and then
attempt to test yourself and then go
back and then you can kind of compare to
see how you how your thought process
compares with my thought process so
anyway I'm gonna quickly read here I'll
skim through this so ok 76 problems or
some distribution I see if this is put
out by some looks like some kind of
German University düsseldorf haven't
heard of that maybe I should have heard
of it but we can see most players fall
into this distribution
estimated a low rating 1871
okay
Everage falling positions you're playing
whites white to move note however that
the best move is not necessarily a
brilliant one some positions are rather
simple some are very tough just choose a
move you would play in the real game
okay so that sounds simple enough
refrain from only trying to find a
combination yeah that makes sense
cool and this is an experiment conducted
by some people at ok all right
we're going to get started I'll click
Next here hopefully this doesn't mess up
like the screen capture thing ok looks
fine example please enter your move by
clicking on the piece you want to move
and then clicking the intended target ok
so click click I assume
drag no I can't okay so click and then
click
okay um so now we're gonna start 76
problems I don't think this is time just
so I guess I could take as long as I
want I don't want to spend all day on
this so let's start and for the easy
ones I'll try and just go quickly yeah
free Queen nice another free Queen rook
e1 check King G to Bishop b4 okay now I
have to think I think that's fine for
white
because King h3 in the end or f3
and then
that should be fine we can take f7 Ricky
one King G to Bishop efore f3 Bishop
take eight Queen to h5 white should be
winning that
okay
what is their Bishop h3 no there's not
Bishop e4 immediately
wait a minute okay I can't let my guard
down
Queen take f7 Bishop efore immediately
but still just f3
h3 there's Rick a one okay freak we okay
this is easy
this is also easy stop upon
mmm oh this is a classic one night to be
four and then if black Queens there's
there's night c2 now actually I wanna I
want to turn this into instructive
moments let's imagine black had some
other pawn let's say black has perhaps a
couple pawns on on h7 and g6
and white goes for a night before the
best move for a black would then be to
play a One Nights preventing the fork
and creating winning chances actually
happen in one of my games once anyway
okay night before a cool oh this is so
easy okay so I'm 7 out of 76 continues
to be easy this is just made in one okay
now we have a positional type example on
a four is screaming to be played is very
thematic move to open a file as blacks
works are not connected
a c4 only winning move I believe
three take nope King Arthur he's not
winning
uh we can take the 1995 this is another
another classic positional example
yeah I'm I'm going with my intuition for
something these positional ones this is
amazing one
a rookie seven wins queen
this is Maidan 1
oh this is uh okay this is a important
one White has to keep the opposition
when black takes upon so King h2 is only
a the only drawing move
um okay now there's some moment to think
Bishop takes c6 leads to some position
just good night versus bad bishop
I don't think there's any tactics 96
doesn't make any sense
fb6 all right what am I talking about
if
if and I take p7 that doesn't work
either so the idea of Bishop take c6 and
then just walking mikeam up to like a
five I don't know if white has a clear
win there but it just looks so appealing
normally I would like to understands
White's plan before committing to take
the nights so Bishop takes c6 B takes c6
hm
maybe it's possible to like put the
knight on e5 and put the King on c5
might be some some technical challenges
but if we don't take on c6 blacks just
gonna play 98 and c6 and b6 just kind of
untangle so we have to take
okay um first position there there's not
like an immediate move that's like
screaming to be played
even though d5 looks attractive actually
d5 looks very attractive and there's
rook d8 but the whole point is to take
on f6 and just damage the structure so
like D 597 Bishop to e6 pawn to a6
White's doing well ninety five does that
lead to anything 95 not as much okay
okay another position rookie one is the
first candidate move
it's also Queenie to check I mean rookie
one just prevents black from castling so
I assume this is the strongest move
you know c5 but I don't think that leads
to much just gives flak the d5 square we
could take on g6 first but that should
only help lack
especially if black is not gonna Castle
and play King our fates then we don't
want the H file to open up for black so
a rookie one
ooh oh this is I think I've seen this
position before this is some kind of
like endgame study where you have to
play kini v get temp on the bishop and
King g4 is is a draw
this is made into
okay this is interesting
neither six it's like a moment there to
find it neither six and then we just
take on f/8 or Knight f6
if queen take f6 we just take okay
rook taking five and then probably
before kind of 7:00 it's nice
right
Moli is like suspicious of potential
counterplay but okay I would seek night
and then get some nice square so the
first thing that comes to mind is Bishop
takes you seven and ninety five
about a third of the way through 23 out
of 76
you
I know if it really does much like
Bishop tick d7 Queen takes you 795 the
the reason why we might take on d7
though is because black wants to play b5
and just completely shut down the bishop
I thought wants to play b5 and we pretty
much have to take on d7 even if it's not
leading to much with with 95 there is
some famous game some famous game
short kramnik worth like the bishop got
stuck I'm pretty sure the bishop got
stuck on b3 and then it was just
devastating for shorts
okay Bishop take Jason more of a
prophylactic move
this is winning the Queen shipped 86
be some meat here
six minus six is nice might have six do
you take out six Queen g14 each eights
Bishop take off six mate and if Knight
have six Keeney and shares Queen take h7
means
can I draw arrows I can not your house
okay
knight Knight f6 just winning
h7 is a classic mate burgage 7 they take
h7 in Queen g7 mates
you
okay
it's a complex position Lag is
threatening some kind of like brook take
a two in queen a7 so the first move I'd
like to play is rook f7 so I think is is
very strong because then if Queen take
g6 there's rook take f8 and we win the
Queen or we win we won we win at least a
knight so Rick f7
there's no more a ticket to the Queen
this just stuck it's got to be real got7
what else to do
this is just Queen to h5 and rook h6
you
okay positions are getting Messier
the first thing that comes to mind is
some kind of clearance tactic with
moving the Queen and then 96 a material
is equal here so I'm wondering if we
can't just play queen take out five my
Queens I got five
I'm just always concerned when we put
our queen on the square that's hanging
like this there could be counter
counterplay potential
Queen take a five queen take each two
take H to ricochet queen h3
so queen taking a five
there's what I want to calculate where
the name may get trapped like rook take
a five-night ecigs say king at six
they take c7 know the the nights not
getting trapped because we attacked the
bishop and we attack b5 okay
probably over thought that but just
wanted to make sure
oh this one I haven't seen this one in a
while I've wanted to show my students
this one I'm gonna take a screenshot to
show my students this one um or maybe
I'll just tell my students to do this
whole this whole test this one is I
believe just a six and then King d6 b6
it's only way to Queen the pawn
you
the one issue with this it's not
satisfying like tactics trainer where
you get to play out the whole variation
this is just a matter of playing the
first move this is convenient my mass is
already hovering over the correct move
is c6 there's going to be a night fork
no matter what black takes back with
this is a classic one rook wait a minute
it's about to say rotate shape but
Bishop can take on a chaise
maybe it's still the right move
the problem is if we play queen h2 first
then the block can play something like
rook FC 8 and there's no there's no mate
queen age 7 King not fades but if we
play rook
well this is getting complicated
if we play rook each eight bishop take
h8 and then let's say we put the Queen
on each two then there's rook a to
ah
this is so weird okay so rogue h8 bishop
take eight shades we have to play Queen
each one not Queen each to I believe to
prevent counter play we play Queen h1
and because after rook a to King take a
- there's no rook a a check so let's say
Queen take C to King a one the Queen on
it each one controls a eight
there's Rick aid anyway
and we can take
seven
oh and we're up a rook
see - then maybe we just move back like
queen take a team g7 Queen h1 for anyone
who didn't follow that the line I'm
calculating is rook h8 bishop take h8
queen h1 rook a to King take a to Queen
take C to King a one um there's no other
checks other than like rook a8 Queen
take a 8 king g7
we go back to h1 because then we're
threatening made into and black has no
time to take the night and we're up at
rook that should be good
each one
sing anything we're okay Trek h8 you
can't take bishop a static Queen h1
and black is pretty limited
move because it's meaning to okay to
taketake they're pretty sure it's
working
hey so I was right I said rookie h8 is
classic I just initially I didn't
realize how deep it is
hopefully I'm right I don't know if I'm
right this is a classic one Queen D
Aidan and Bishop g5 double check and
then rip t8 mates
rookie four I feel like I've seen this
one before Ricky four is just crushing
because we're threatening mates
the queen is pinched the g7 square gotta
work
we should take every two
rook take we have Queen c8 and that's
mates
okay this is looking strong for whites
just a question how do we have we win
this
I mean rook take g7 there's a lot of
Canada moves Bishop take h7
each five there's even like Queenie for
we need four is a funny move
if that works though maybe it does work
maybe it doesn't work
maybe I should just start calculating
like some forcing some forcing thing but
I'm really
black doesn't have a media counterplay
there's no immediate check so we can
start having fun okay rook take g7
pretty much has to take because we're
threatening work take h7
materials equal here - okay so rook take
g7 King take g7 Queen g4
teenage shades and then like just queen
age five
I was back defending each 7:00
the g7 King dick g7 queen g4 kimuchi
queen h5
King g8 but then we take on our six okay
you
hmm
so this position that seems like black
has countered place we have to do
something somewhat quickly there's rook
d7
okay there's rook d7 which is
interesting because if King take than me
let's just made into if Bishop take we
have Queenie seven can see a queen take
a fate
and then if King b7 me we play queen bee
1806 and then Queen eight mate
so I'm curious about okay so rook d7
King c8 we just have rook c7
kindiy a queen e7 made of King beards
where's the follow-up
probably has some strong discovery
Rufe t7
King c8
Brooksie 7 can be 8
black wants to play a d2 and just be
annoying
[Music]
use vertex e6 check
and King eight
oh there's just rook f7 after king ba
just work out seven we win the rook that
should be good enough
and then the queen comes in
so rook d7 Kings he a rook c7 King b8
and then rook f7 and like King a
triptych f8 and Queenie sevens coming
okay
i smooth
that pops out here is Queen d5 to check
because it's the only checking position
but does it work Queen d5
- 85 shipped 85
by the way I'm about halfway through
almost halfway through oh this is going
to be a long video Wow
hopefully my computer can handle this it
should Queen g5
taketake if
kingi cheats
g6 Quinta hhg 1787
I'm not seeing meat there
because we can get the same position of
King Effie
he7 takes you seven
wait a minute we're just winning the
Queen I forgot the Queen's hanging on g4
and them were just up at Bishop Queen d5
taketake and we win the Queen so focused
on winning the king
initially we can win the bishop the very
lease okay queen d5 this is a classic
one I believe it's just queen b7
and then there's issues for black
this is a Philidor position
the first time I ever do OGN I had to
know this position is what we call a
third ranked defense or the fill door or
if you're blacking in the six ring
defense
this is classic when you change
Messick's
I think the move here is is a five
five in King C one to get distant
opposition
this type of position this is uh this is
why you need to understand that position
because if we if we play something that
King see - King g4 is just winning the
e5 taking five if you can see one it's
just a draw we keep opposition you can
never allow the King to like to help
guide the pawn while being in front of
the pond so II five
by the way I hope the background noise
isn't too distracting um I'm in an air
B&B and like a kind of busy street and
there's bells going off but hopefully
it's okay
okay I've forty two problems down
not sure if this is going to be
positional or tactical
and it's just white to play find the
best move
nothing immediately pops out unless c5
is really strong c5 could be
could be the move
in sort of a positional plan sacrifice
because B takes e5 and Bishop to b5
and then the night is kind of weird to
the fens has to play c6 and then we play
Bishop c4 it's probably worth giving
away upon
se5 is my first choice so far
so if we do something slow like rook D
to unlock just plays Queen e7 rook 81
York 88
there's no tactics against the e55
I don't think
three but that runs into e4 tactics for
black
five we want to activate the
LightSquared bishop and this line with
c5 b takes e5 Bishop b5 c6 Bishop c4
blacks bishop just kind of dies this is
Bishop a6 in that position but the pawn
structure is terrible we have like
Knight d2 Knight see for ideas or naive
for ideas d6 could be weak it's got to
be good
okay King is on Yeats
White's King is on e3 what's material
materials equal
are we just mating is it just made in
three Queen take e7 King to e7 or g7
just may than three
in the year 96 mate
whoa I have a feeling it's not Bishop
take T five
because that's just a draw right I draw
Oh soso draw
I know the position without being see
ponds where you have the LightSquared
Bishop but you can't win a seventh pond
so I assume it's the same thing but I'm
curious if we play Bishop take d5 and
then let's imagine we get the White King
to c6 and blacks King is on b8 and it's
blacks move
if King eight we would have King c7
mates lift King c8 it's just a draw I
believe so that means we we just take
with the pawn and it's an easy win right
these are keen catches a sea pawn
as a funny one
a bishop a3 is begging to be played
because black doesn't have a dark for a
bishop and we prevent black from
castling
you
interesting position the first move that
comes to mind is bishop yet threatening
queen
t7 and there's no Queen there's no Queen
g4 checks our queen is actually and a
good defensive place on a for the bishop
ei there's queen
f-five and rookie six maybe
so so keen see seven like Bishop eaking
see seven then we play Queen d7 King b6
queen take d6 everything flows
yeah so I think Bishop e8 is relatively
forcing because we throw in mate in one
Rena five or queen h3 are the only tries
and then I think we have rookie six
and what does black do there's just no
defense to d7 there's no time for Bishop
e5 doesn't move black would love to play
while it's playing for a win if we play
King g5 then there's rook h1 it's just a
draw
so the only move to play for a win is
King f5
I think it's winning cuz Rick h5 King a
former gauge 14 f3 brook h3 King g2 and
then you have to win mean versus rook
first thing that comes to mind is rook
take C 1666 Queen take T five king 285
bishop efore mates it's got to be good
it's equal material
nice sack exchange than sack a'queen
meet the king in the center
okay
this position
equal material
Queen is on c7 there's a lot of like
loose type of things for black
everything is sort of defended
it seems like this should be tactical
maybe 96
wait I take e6
F take you six
the ship g6 check
you know fates
rook take you six
and then if Queen takes c7 there's rook
e8 me as Queen te6 is Queen D a mutant
too
that's pretty forcing
I take e 6f taking six fish of g6
ah is this the this well-known position
where you have to walk around from this
side and take the a4 pawn a king b1
Keaney 1582 in d5 in a3 and white is
winning and then there's some funny line
like if King b1 black plays a3 we have
to play b3
and then king
six here here here
and if you're here
yeah that's funny yeah King b1 I've seen
this before this is a funny one and show
it to students and it can can really
stump a lot of people
hey what's going on here
rook t8 rook ta was the first move that
came to mind but now I thought bishops
88 and then there's Queenie a mate's
rook ta truck take ta there's Queen take
b7 that's nice you'll get tactic
I'm a bit curious if both sides can
Castle because that could be relevant to
the position
going to assume yes
you
but black or white can't castle right
away
the question can my castle eventually
there might be some relevant lines
what to do here
could just be positional like just play
Queen efore and get a good night
this black wants to sorry I assumed
black wants to queenside castle if it's
legal build a pressure against d2
94 immediately
84
[Music]
black is up a pawn pawn structure is
pretty bad for black
not entirely sir
move
you
queen g4 is a move
you
between g4 there's Queen f5
you
Queeny Forrestal my first choice
there's an irony for it just looks so
good
and there's so many like positional
ideas like when you have the not any
four there's no real breakthrough for a
black along the files we put the King on
you to work on f1 and we try and lift
over
maybe gather rook to g3 to start winning
the G pawns
mark would be forced to tick
you
yeah I think white wants the Queen trade
I'm not entirely sure about this one
we need for our then locking queenside
castle anyway but it should be similar
because black beans like castles we take
the Queen Keaney to 94
you
crazy position
cereals probably not relevant to the
black is up upon there's no Queenie one
check immediately which is good so how
do we kill the king
maybe queen g6 queen g6 actually work
66 we made into
there's no media counterplay we're
threatening to take on g7 it's gotta be
it
okay 22 more to go
I've don't remember what time I started
so hopefully this video can stay under
an hour
we'll see
okay what's going on here there is a
nice space advantage for whites material
is equal
no immediate tactics that I see
no immediate position ideas
you
I mean there's g4 g4 is an idea
probably have to start identifying
central resources g4s kind of
forcing line of tg4 percept g6 King the
eight
and see how that could be good
you
and c4 is a move the trine access this
is g6 square or night
sometimes structures
this white would be hesitant to play c4
cuz it slightly weakens d4
but sometimes it's worth opening up the
center
like c4
[Music]
issue is I don't know if there's a
threat yes the threat is just see take
t5 open the C file
and then box kings
boxing then doesn't want to Castle
queenside that's a bit more stuck
you
considering other random ideas like
night left 193 even rook g1 to prepare
or h3 to prepare g4 there's also a 4 try
and play a 5
No
you
I feel like I'm liking c4 because it's
only like clear idea in the position but
if it's that's drawing
I could keep analyzing c4d take c4
probably take with night there the
Bishop Dacey for the light square bishop
is a monster so then at some point black
will play Bishop c7 but look if we
imagine like c4 G takes c4 Knight takes
e4 Bishop c7 I can probably already play
96
yeah I feel like the positions opening
up in White's favor go for this
twenty-one more problems
we're getting more difficult
well this position doesn't seem the
previous one was very pleasant for white
but this seems not so impressive blacc
controls the only open file
equal material lots of color bishops
be amazing if we can open up this
diagonal for the bishop
pawn on e4
like a four bucks
some pissant
so maybe the the move is to okay I have
an idea Bishop f1 Bishop c4 and Bishop
d5 I don't know if that plan can be
prevented because they're all white
squares maybe I could play Queen e6
26 is kind of annoying
you
it's all about getting the bishop to d5
because then why it would then just be
good probably a bishop Athlon queen e6
and maybe just maybe rook t3 there
I'd trade off
pair of rooks
now this Godby Bishop f1 though just
because the bishop is doing nothing on
g2
I just don't know what to do after
Queenie six
and try to put the Queen on a four it's
a prepare Bishop c4 just may be
reasonable like Bishop f1 Queen e6 Queen
c2 the play Queen a4
rook HD a queen a for rook T to Bishop
c4
we have six f1
I think this is the best approach
Queen g6 working queen g6
take
while queen g6 it's a thematic idea when
White has so many pieces attacking the
queen g6 fthe 697 King h8 I take g6 and
its mate
in support 97 would be double-check
and if black ticks with
Weymouth Queen g6 it shake g5
I guess we just take back with H pawn
still can't be taken
take our six okay
you
looks like a classic like Reuben scene
if there's any like
tactical ideas
feel like if there were tactical ideas
it would be very obvious
okay less than 20 left
you
like if the bishop were on CA we would
love to take on f6 and play Queen e4
I feel like this is a position I like I
should know what to do here they're just
such a normal type of structure
we can take on that sex play Bishop e4
just seems to be okay for black
in 95 the normal move could lose a d4
pawn
c3 is a move
does black want to do
but I might want to play c5 soon
you
have a feeling this is the most
difficult position so far
it's just very easy I'm overlooking
something but don't quite see what to do
there's a lot of normal move see three
this is just one of those positions you
just play a move like rook d1
and then you put the question to black
actually rook t1 looks nice because rook
a d1 we prevent he prevents u5 we
prevent any like Bishop take out three
shenanigans
and you put play rook 81 because we want
the other look to you one
it just seems like so
but rook t1 and if this were a blitz
game this is probably the first move I
play
five
yes with rook d1 we have ideas of then
playing 95 because the D pawn would be
defended by tactics okay rook - you won
I think that is a
position where it was just another thing
in the formal move what is going on here
the first thing that comes to mind is
Knight g7
to save the nights
seven weaken the king g6
somes looks long happening I think
a taking f7
makini has to move to see it in the
movement
I've been a g7
this black could try and survive it
doesn't have to take the nights
then I mean it should be winning after
96
as well get the King to g6 we'll start
winning pawns
another normal position I play this
opening as as black actually I played
the same structure so this is white to
move I mean the most common plan is to
play d4 and with a record on beat one
before is kind of
it's just egging to be played
tactics here each sevens defended when
there's another plan of 95 which could
also be strong
but 95 can often run into a move like
night night 6 to d7
and then there's ideas of f6 and just
things get tricky but with before
plan of b5 is just so clear and white
wants to create some minority attack
right b4 b5 I thought there's a six why
plays a four
if I plays b5 its weakening to c6
you
yeah I probably have to lean go with
that
as I'm thinking nights
Kings still at 95 967 and then some f4 I
like black and trade it's okay okay I'll
play b4
Kings Indian structure
getting tired 16 more problems this
could be long if every problem gets more
difficult
you
and the first thing I'm looking at was
taking on a chore and playing Knight b5
and the Queen can come back really no no
progress this could be a positional type
idea where we just avoid the tray the
bishops and play Bishop g1
also consider g3
g3 is probably not good though because F
take g3 HCG three Bishop g5
yeah I would be losing material
you
okay so do we take on h4
Bishop h1 or do we play Queenie one
the eventual plan light
who wants to go for a c5
which means we probably can allow p6
like if we imagine Bishop g1 black just
plays b6 it's very hard to play c5
because we don't necessarily want to
play b4 open up the Queen side too much
you
mmm
you
you
I could just be misjudging the physician
Bishop is not the best piece
so there's a line I'm looking at bishop
they use for Queen th were c5
he takes you five and then d6
splode the center and c6
you
this is tough oh I see the timestamp
I've been
for 15 minutes okay that's fine
video can go I want the video to be over
two hours but just over an hour will
hopefully be okay
what else to consider
there's no way to deflect the Queen I
have to do something with this bishop I
feel like I feel like this position is
more about on your standing rather than
calculation
there's night 2g1
looks a bit strange though
you
it could be calculation if we take on h4
and then have something immediate like
g4 looking that works
you
there's another perspective to take on
this is the fact that after a bishop
take h4 Queen Daggett's were black has
nothing developed on the Queen side and
white is doing better with developments
continue
like night b5
and then go for a c5 like Bishop dagesh
for Quinta gage fortnight b5 rook f7 and
c5 something like that and I have take
10 d6 and that could be strong
you
thing is after 95 there's 96 iconic 4.9
a success
probably a good resource for black
you
ah
it's funny all these lines are involving
the shift a gauge for a first move but I
want to just have some confidence after
a bishop to a gauge for Queen to H work
maybe I could start with c5 and then if
D takes e5 I didn't like d6 earlier
because Bach had c6 but maybe after G
takes e5 we play Knight b5
and going for d6 and if 9066 c6 is g7
messy but that night can come to c3
I'm just gonna go for Bishop take h4 I'm
not entirely confident but it seems like
there's some interesting possibilities
for whites
involving the c-5 move
okay this looks like some men getting
study
is it just bishop f1
but if Mike wins the F pine it could be
a draw so I have to calculate Bishop f1
King f3 each for
okay push the Bethel on King i3h for
King g4
team g4n Quinta got four books let's
start with king g4 and I think Bishop h3
of h3 Quinta
for Bishop [ __ ] five king g3 it's just
a drawing though
so maybe just bishops 83 after King g4
and if taken each for we were in time
with that came to the fete not fun if
keen take a four then we play Bishop e2
and blacks
zooks long
after kini v h5 it's winning
okay so Bishop etholon King F 3 H 4
I've determined Bishop take t3 is
winning for white so after Bishop
etholon King f3h for those can take f4
Bishop Bishop h3
same kinds of one
controlled fd2 just king take t2
okay mr. thorn
I didn't even consider it I should take
out five
why not probably because King f3 yeah
King Arthur it can take out for is wait
Bishop take out five King f3h for King
take and then Bishop e6
but then s5 and the king can kind of
come around okay
it's just Rick g7
please let this be an easy one rook g7
there's King h8
firk g7 king day g7 we win the Queen
with Bishop to g5 if King h8
you
King edge here we can take on e5
and then if Queen Dixie - we mates in -
okay I'm taking less time here - like
triple check everything because I'm
tired I want this to be over with 13
more problems
Queenie 8 there's Queen f8
do we do
you
there's some deflection tactic Bishop f4
this one uh I haven't seen this I've
seen this idea before but not the
specific position it's Rick take a six
this is a really nice background trick
um there's a book by Yusupov called
chess lessons this is a green book he's
a whole chapter I like that crank mate I
remember this one from his book it's
like some
out of nowhere move rook take a six and
everything works
I think they better work
what is this ah so if we promote to rook
then there's Ricky five and it still
meets
wants to win
I sorry if we promotes a queen we
promote secrete nice 45 so if we promote
to rook it's just a draw though
so we play tonight g6 preventing or g5
oh yeah cause of Knights d7 there are D
worksheets and we could repeat but
Knight g6 should be the winning move
rook g1 king of two
okay
it's getting tricky
I have an idea about this one the first
line I came to mind is Bishop g3
threatening to take on f2 we played it
black plays d3 Bishop take F to d2
and Bishop II one because if I promote
to Queen and stalemates in fact promotes
to
promote we just take on g-suits to draw
and if black promotes to rook we have
kini to that should also be a draw rook
a one Bishop g3
we'll play push before and win the pawn
and Bishop g3
because I feel like if we play Bishop g5
the King can escape and that could be
problematic this is just so forcing
push-up G 3 D 3 take
let's do it
mmm additional chess is it f4
f4 is a thematic move
that for probably is just bad because
Bishop d6 and Kings on h2
g4 because White has more nights
5 + h 5 could just be G 4
idea of ninety-two mystery
[Music]
Skol with intuition try and speed
through some of these final final
problems okay less than ten left
exactly 10 left
math is difficult okay I want a back
drink meets black so is there some
interference like 94 and 96 first two
moves that come to mind not sure what
the differences
for Queen Diggy for we mates oh if 96 we
don't make because Queen take e6 in this
queen g8 so 94 has to be the move
we're threatening the rook and worth
writing the Queen that's beautiful
the disposition queen be on
you
okay let's count material material is
equal uh let's look at resources g4 is a
resource it should be for as a
positional move ephors attacked though
it just bc3
and the pond
could be queen bee for this trade
you
these ideas was like rookie 3
see three
you
this one could take a while I think
since I'm not sure I mean white has a I
guess a rich position there's a lot of
ideas
work a3
I take d4 rook c3 and then Queenie two
mates that would be tragic
probably not rookie three because they
take d4 it's too strong
and c3 is not the move I wants to play
cousin Bishop becomes bad on d2
it could be Queen before
and then it's just positional play
the problem no there's no problem with
queen bee for I was thinking Queen
before night 84 but then white just
plays Knight 84 wins a piece so a queen
before I think is the best way to kind
of solve the issue on d4 and even though
it's trade in Queens where blacks King
is maybe attackable leads to a
positional game where okay black takes
one before we got the Bishop on me for
amazing piece that a7 pawn is always
backwards ideas of king d2 and doubling
on a file and go for a queen before
I've shown my students this many times
kini h1 not going to spend any time
long-distance opposition
okay
well why it is looking to be in pretty
good shape here
96 black wants to play Knight c8 most
likely
question is how do we optimize or
maximize advantage
if p5 is playable Bishop e5 Brooksie one
[Music]
they take p7 doesn't make any sense by
g5s a move my g5 has a thread of night a
p7
would probably have to defend
bh6 but then actually those two threats
with my g5 n IG v h6 96 Quint 86-90 p7
get weird after night ch
you
age six
that gets
that's pretty weird it might be good for
whites just not sure
you
you
you
fives a move
B 5 a 6
you
so a five-night c8 a six-night 86
don't know if that leaves so much
you
b5 doesn't seem to lead to much
you
looking at lines like with bishop
five and rook b1 or look to see one
doesn't seem to quite work
you
okay I'm going to go back to this Knight
g5 line so I dismissed it because it was
too weird but maybe I should look closer
because my g5 and I see it's not
playable h6 I think is a key variation
and then I want to take on e6 Queen
Ziggy six night take if we can get the
Knights back to g6 everything is good
but then there's Knight to c8
the nights kind of stuck
you
I just didn't see what to do there
see it and there's Bishop a6 to defend
maybe just Bishop Asics rook b8
hold onto the pond
worst-case scenario we Castle and give
it back
you
oh wait there's we play a five and
slippage of a six create an outpost on
b7
so no g5
rookie hates it's another line IG v rook
v
spend enough night
does anything
you
spend so much time trying to make that
work
there's rook b8
and stuff
cuz I'm black black man has ideas of h6
or nights eh
it's kind of sad
I haven't considered g4 yet probably for
good reason
meet so much Hey
[Music]
almost done with this test but so
difficult problem
you
you
I don't want to make a move that's just
not well informed
I feel like Knight g5
g58 PHS isn't productive
so some concrete reason
you
you
and ideally why would like to prevent I
see it's it's so difficult
I don't even know what else to look for
here
looks like to try and combine the
resources in different ways what did I
say after 85
I said 8 5 XE 8 immediately because a 6
and I take D 6 I'm missing something
there
you
should also note there's rook b8 after a
five
but that should be good cuz then I have
a six Bishop 8 and the bishop is is
stuck if I get pawn to b5
okay so a five-night see it
a 696 pawn to d6 bishops attacks has to
move to c8
but maybe I just played b5 Night Moves
in Queen Bee for
so be 595 Queen before
95 or than those ripped Yeats
95 still lachman's upon
you
if I might see it
he's six
it's difficult
let me look at that line one more time a
five-night c8 a six-night 86 pawn to g6
bishop c8 b 595 queen bee for rook d8
you
95 Quint 86
in 86 86 I don't see anything
you
really not sure maybe it's just a normal
move play
look to play b5
play Bishop d3
rook c1
you
I really don't know
four feet
okay I don't want to take too long on
this I wonder if it will show me like
the answer is hopefully it does
afterwards
I'm still looking for resources
tick
okay five a five and my GFI they just
seem so close to working
you
I mean maybe it could just be positional
like a five-night see we can just take
on c8 play a six
the bishops kind of stuck okay I'm just
gonna play a five five hundred percent
sure but moving on
it's really hoping this would be an easy
one is it easy as it just Bishop d2
this is probably going to be another
difficult one
this our most an hour and 15 minutes in
too much energy left
wait okay I have an idea Queen B 3 with
seven zeros Equal Rights so Queen B 3
black house to play Rekha fades and then
Bishop d2 there's b4
forgot about before
I mean there's Bishop take f7 Queen b3
check
don't lead to anything
fifty-two before
you
are the 95
wait okay I might be confident with this
Bishop take s7 King dick f7 and there's
a
95 and other line
sign after Queen b3 those King g6
be good for light somehow
to Queen b3 immediately your cafe Bishop
d2 b4 Knight g5
let me just attack out seven three times
five could get murky
but I'm kind of tired
for queen bee three I think
in v3 Queen b3 or cafe Bishop d2 be for
Knight g5
I'd see five
you just queen c4 there's 96 then we
went up on
okay queen bee through this
so
okay five left
tricky position what's material sequel
material like house center pawns more
space
we
to get to d4
how would that work move the brook
somewhere
gofer b5 probably doesn't make any sense
three
black has a new media threats
you
this is tough
I don't really have any candidate moves
yet
move the bishop somewhere
what does might want to do here
like one of these positions is just not
clear what to do
f-for than Bishop ticket for
to g5
to
and be good as Bishop f6
you
well if it's just rook a to the funny
move only square the rook really can't
be attacked live work be to Bishop f6 if
rook see - there's III brocade - with
the idea of 92 94 xbox still has III
then f3
we still want to play now you too
looks solid okay I'm gonna go for that
cuz it's only idea that I see
I think this is an easy one I think it's
just rook b2 and then if Rick takes e7
we play rook b8 Chuck he moves and then
rook d7 and we win
look II - king f7 lyric b7
I think in d5 now should be winning
okay nearing the end three more left's
stuff
20 minutes
you
okay so this is
equal material
this could just be positional we
nights somewhere
more effective
there's a funny idea here to play g4 g5
and try and get the e5 square
probably too weird though lack of a g5
so 92 could be a normal move
just like b3a for
wait I see at attic
but there's a tattoo here to play a for
immediately the bishop has to take
because if the bishop moves I win the c6
pawn so Bishop take a fourth and queen a
three and then the bishop moves back to
b5 and we just take on b5 Queen take a
three rugby seven beautiful
the feeling this has to do something
crank and the brook on c5 and before is
a candidate move
sequel material okay bye
to play 94
relatively quickly
so let's say before
there would be okay there's not deserve
there 94-94 brooked 84
why twins at least upon an outline
so before let's say rook c4
you
this could just not be tactical this
could be just get some small advantage
rook t5 is a move
you
singing b49 take P 4 and then 95
oh but that just losses upon the rip
takes you wanna take see one night back
to c6
so maybe some rook t5 move
structure we're liking
d5 pawn to d5 94 King G three white
should be slightly better more active
King F for coming
you
as well as to do all these other moves
seem just to be equal
there's my c5
then Blackett slighty forum
Aoife
you
Oh
could calculate a bit further rook t5
taketake 94 king D 3 king e7
a for king D six F for probably f 6
tick tick
maybe 94
just be equal I'm gonna play route d5 so
I want this to be over her last position
76 out of 76
I mean I want to take on a six you know
if that leads to anything
Queen take out six D six Queen take T
six
because it just be like Queen g7
some threat of queen there Brooke take
f6
you
okay let's count material
White's up upon no materials equal I
think White's up upon
all over the place
I would like to utilize some idea
at some point playing pawn d6
maybe we just play Queen h4 where is a
bishop going
actually yeah Queen h4 has a double
threat of queen day g4 and Merc take f6
given that there would be a potential
pin so like Queen h4 at Bishop g7 Queen
rook take f-16 take on 66 and there's no
more Queen take g6
I'm done okay well done before we will
provide you with an estimate we have
some questions uh helpful okay okay cool
I have taken
seriously oh I've taken yeah I took this
pretty seriously maybe the last problems
I for a bit less serious but okay it was
overall very serious how many of the 676
problems did I know already
now I have to think I mean the
checkmates and there is some that I like
I knew the idea I just it was a new
position um but like that can be one
problem I knew I'm gonna assume that
like it was just
the endgame positions they've a lot of
them I had like no one before I'm gonna
say about ten that's a reasonable
estimate
how many of the 76 problems did you
solve with help of computer or database
0 ok
tens of your estimates
it was my impression the difficulty
increased its it really increase with
each problem because some are easy
towards the end
after a correct answer
it wasn't random either because the
first
the first problems were much easier than
the final problem so I probably say this
increase after a correct answer and
decrease yeah how much fun I had fun at
the beginning like a lot were feel good
but towards the end I mean it was
stressful but overall I had fun I'll say
I'll say five out of seven so weird
scale okay next
how old am i oh man am I gonna give my
age away to the whole YouTube ecosystem
I guess people can just look me up is
yeah where am i from
USA
do I have yes yes
I don't even know I don't want to check
my national rating
second check it
oh by the way okay there's a cool way to
check it I'll just use this as a plug
for a self-promotion we can go to I am
Rosen comm I have to update my websites
but if you click my these ratings if you
click this will open in a new tab you
get my us homepage my us profile
whatever and my rating is 24 24 39 okay
so 24 39 and if we go back to my website
you can click feed a
23:55 I'm losing a lot of points after
my last two tournaments so thankfully it
has not updated yet you have a blitz
rating not bullet lightning
um I do but I I haven't used ICC in in a
long time
Wow this is probably an old site because
they they don't have leech s here
I have something on the chest doc yeah
but I don't know what my chest accom
rating is budget chest calm
so how do I check my ratings
how do I check my ratings oh here's our
ratings blitz is 2431 okay
24:31
okay next
there they're making me give them so
much data how much time do I spend
playing chess let's say an hour a day I
stream a lot though and recently I've
been playing like four hours a day cuz
tournaments
I'll just say on average say three hours
wait three hours per day that's 20 hours
per week about 20 hours some days I
don't play any chess
[Music]
say 15 I'll just say 18 okay
how many chest books have you read in
the last few years zero
two years
I've read portions of chess books
have I read four books I'll just say one
probably the the number of portions of
books that I've read I've told ups I'd
like one full book how many blitz games
have you played in the last 12 months
I see my profile
let's
can I see the number of games that I
played
you
so feed
789
rated games that's but that's total
oh gosh 103 hours
we need blood schemes I'm just gonna say
like 800 between like Ches calm and
everything else how many years have I
played chess seriously
17
how many tournaments tournament games
have I played in last two years they're
difficult questions I want to look up
exact numbers as I could
I'm rule
and stats
if you're a u.s. player this is a cool
page to look at because it gives you all
these stats so the last twelve months
I've played I only played 23 games but
that's us rated I played a lot of
international events
double that for two years let's say 50
and then I'll add like
I have to add a lot for international
chess
I just say 100 I'll say 80
about rights
Kenny 80 how many hours a week spend
playing and analyze
these could be different
playing and analyzing
Oh playing and analyzing so that
includes playing
I'll just say like 25
it's a lot
rich
I mean recently it's been a lot more
than okay an entire life how many hours
do I receive lessons by a trainer wow
that's a difficult question
our it was like an hour a week for most
of my developments think second grade
through
through high school so let's say ten
years an hour a week
but then it's not an hour every week but
we'll just say 50 because I went to a
lot of camps like long seminars
so 50 times 10 is 500
hours
overall I consider
wanna be arrogance but
I'm trying to think of an email address
I can share without
wait if I'm interested in other
even reading this oh no I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna push me village s next
it gave me a thing
based on your move choices our estimate
eloah is 2423 with 90 percent confidence
interval
I wonder did they use my rating too baby
okay they probably didn't use the rating
to make that judgment okay that's cool
that's pretty accurate
as my us rating
I guess I'd perform slightly lower than
my us rating microphones higher than I
feed a reading Nilo is feeding rights
item response theory
anyway I'm gonna end it here it's long
recording over an hour and a half I
would be curious to see how you guys did
and see how accurate this test was so if
you want to leave a comment in the video
uh how did it go did you struggle any
problems you had questions about or want
to analyze or did you receive the same
problems or different problems I would
be curious so so yeah I'll leave it
there if you want to see any specific
types of content I did this video purely
because I received a message from
someone who just told me to take the
tests now happily uh respond to him with
with hopefully a link to this video so
yeah I will I will see you guys in the
future bye